So let's look at these features to see what would be
the perfect feature list for Debbie. Bill splitting. That would definitely be
one of them, because Debbie is very money conscious, so she'd
want to split the bill. delivery, definitely, because Debbie doesn't have a car.
So definitely not pickup, because she doesn't have a car, so
there's no way she could go pick up a pizza. Coupons definitely,
because she is very value conscious. I don't think name of
the farmer, or photos of ingredients would be very useful for her,
that might be too extra, to much extra for her. And also multiple payment
options would be consistent with the bill
splitting, because different people might have different
payment options. So I think this would be a really good feature list that
would make Debbie feel like we made a pizza app that's just for her.